let's dive into functions we need to uh
think back to what happened on Tuesday
what we established okay we talked about
functions as big category we pretty
would even put down an important
definition for functions does anyone
remember in a sentence what is a
function it's a function high five couch
am most unhelpful yes very good okay so
when you've got two quantities two
numerical quantities two variables right
and they're connected to each other
they're related in some way good morning
if they are related more broadly
speaking we don't necessarily call them
functions because they're related we
call them relations very good but
there's this specific kind of relation
that we're interested in what what makes
you know any two quantities that are
connected will be a relation but which
special kinds of relations are functions
what extra piece of future do we have
outputs and inputs okay now what is it
about the outputs inputs that I want to
know for our functions yeah you kinda
we're very close there right the
critical thing and hopefully you have
this written down if I could boil it
down is um for each input will have one
one output
okay it has to have only one and so what
we did was we concluded this was right
the very end we said if you have like
the graph of a relation right where
there's a relationship between x and y
okay if you have that graph what this
amounts to visually is to say if I slice
through with a vertical line at any
point a vertical line that vertical line
will represent a particular input like x
equals to zero and x equals zero as an
input etc right now it's my vertical
line if I can go anywhere and it only
hits the graph once that means it only
ever has one output and that's a
function right so you can see this
parabola here is a tick okay
but when you come across
Circle for a whole bunch of values if I
put that vertical line in I don't get
just one point of intersection I'll get
two right so this is not a function okay
it's it's still a relation they still
connected but not in the way they're
particularly interested not a funny okay
so that's just to get your head back in
the right space there's the idea we're
now going to introduce a bit of notation
and language here okay now just let me
make a bit of an aside the notation
tends to be a very dry thing to learn
like like wide left to make things so
have I putting all these symbols on here
I want to try like in one minute
convince you that actually is something
that's very powerful works diagrams and
notation they're things
terminology they're things that appear
in the syllabus which you need to learn
like these are things which people
decided are really important but why
okay where's diagrams and notation there
are really three flavors of the same
thing what are words and pictures and
like we had suppose in our company what
are they trying to do all three of them
have a common goal they're try them
they'll try to make your life easier but
more importantly the way that they make
your life easy is if you and I have a
common set of words we could call that a
language right if we have a language
then we can talk to each other and if we
already have a common language we can't
we can't communicate right can you see
how diagrams are kind of an extension of
that right I could say the definition of
a circle is it's the set of points that
are equidistant from one central
location or I could draw a circle right
and you say oh of course that's what
you're me right rather than has to
unpack all of those words
and lastly notation right if you
remember you might have done earlier
a topic where you had symbols like this
there you go
that might seem familiar to some of you
okay now what does that mean like there
are no words there but you guys pretty
much all know what that means right
what's it talking about talking about
pair triangles right
you've got names for each of them and
they are similar to each other okay now
I couldn't write that sentence right
triangle that no-no is similar to
triangle interlock right what a similar
mean alone but I boil it down into like
this tiny little space and that's the
power of notation okay
words are thermal right diagrams are
visual and notation is symbolic we use
symbols right
these symbols all the time for instance
I'm wearing a symbol right now some
managed will be very touchable I thought
I'm wearing this because it means
something right and you could look at it
you could say immediately I know this
what that's referring to okay I don't
even need to say anything the symbol
speaks for itself okay so all of these
all of these are about communication
mathematics is about more than just can
I get an answer it's about can I speak
to someone can we talk to each other and
convey me really really complex rich
meaning in a variety of ways whichever
way suits best okay so that's why we're
learning notation for functions so that
we can speak in a more powerful way and
in a more concise way all right
yeah mercifully it is not actually that
much notation for functions so let me
show you some substance with
carrying on from the sundry if I say
this y equals f of X that's that's the
way I read that by the way y equals f of
X in fact it's so important right now
the way I say it what I'm saying is Y is
a function of X Y is a function of X I
can write what Y is right just in terms
of a whole bunch of X's right so I might
say y equals f of X where well what is
that function what does it look like
here's an example this one here it's
something like x squared minus 5 that
thing over there x squared minus 5
that's a function I can put numbers in
there ok another way of thinking about
it as well as this and this are now
related is my relation to computing this
is kind of like a rule right if you give
me an X and input I can give you an
output
I know exactly what more than talked
about now I can shortcut this a little
bit right because the whole point of
notation is to make things concise right
so in parallel to this I could say
exactly the same thing by saying is
right see how I said f of X there right
meaning it's a function of X well I can
I don't need to have this little man in
here right you see it f of X is equal to
that so I'm just gonna write this okay
now you're actually used to seeing this
we see this all the time it's just that
we don't we don't explicitly say Y is a
function of X we just kind of imply it
you see that like a thousand times y
equals x squared minus five once code
four is that Y is not just another
number it's a function and it's a
function of X okay so let me just write
that down right why
from color Y is a function of X which is
another way of saying the value of y
depends on the value of x let me say
that yeah the value of y depends on the
value of X
now once I say this this unlocks some
more language for us which you might see
and I hope this will explain it right
we've been talking about the inputs and
outputs right X is our input that's what
you shove into the function and Y is
what you get out is the output but when
you see if Y depends on X right and y
necks are both numbers that can change
right so they're variables yeah they can
vary
therefore as well as calling them inputs
and outputs right this is the X is the
input Y is the output right they're both
variables but because Y depends on X Y
is what we call the dependent variable
it's a variable it can change right
there's a whole bunch of different
values in here is that Y can take but it
depends on this guy right X on the other
hand well it's not dependent I can make
it I can make it 200 300 minus 100 I can
make it anything I like so therefore
it's not a dependent variable what's the
opposite of dependent independent we
call this guy the independent variable
if you want a somewhat coincidental but
the helpful way to remember which ones
which write input is independent okay
you can make it anything you like but
the output well you need to know what
that one is first it depends on that one
okay so I'm pretty well language here so
you understand what's going on when you
see it you'll know what's talking about